death of aluminium thickness yes you
actually mean someone was the pariah of
I meant Paragon yeah he pulled me up
about it he's brutal like I'll write
piece of content and he goes through and
there'll be one typo use oh did you spot
starter again I sent that I sent that
article for Muslim fitness off to cup a
front Muslim fitness actually the other
day same one weird taste like pet it's
not bad how do you really know won't
Apple yeah mmm apparent lovely yeah
very caffeinated though heavily Catholic
yeah that's something you are risk
because of your severe and chronic I
feel like I'm trying to dock a spaceship
that's not because we talked about
docking last time right they went on for
ages yeah um so we've got choices what
we're gonna talk about today I think
confidence no although I'm what weeds
boogie saying Chris said pariah oh it's
at the end of it I'm not bitter right I
met Mario yep there you go on the foot
thank you so yet again we're videoing
and everything now is going on YouTube
people who were listening you're going
to be able to subscribe on YouTube but
I'm gonna be one of those people who
says don't forget to subscribe
soon however you've worn the same pants
that you did for life effort love Island
so it looks as though we recorded all of
these in the same position we're in even
in the same position I think Johnny
might be wearing some of daylight now
though
it is so similar I'm actuary different
jeans t-shirt under I've got possible
pair of shorts a little okay well I'm
all you do is buy all the way into the
people that are gracefully people that
are just listening now but just getting
these little tidbits that you got
YouTube channel which I should loop open
loop open the yeah exactly the main
it'll be closed I want to know what just
what shade of possible are those short
sacred nuts gonna have to go subscribe
and by the way a video might look they
are there a kind of like yeah man we
don't give too much away no I mean it's
it's really great to fiddle the tail
whether they are in fact Lyla yeah it's
really interesting I also desperately
need a haircut but that's that's by the
by so we've got your hair grows does it
just grow it's just gets larger does you
know holding its larger yeah so it's
like a privet hedge you know summer I
mean yeah I keep just be able to easily
harder cover scissors yeah yeah yeah so
blow it means to not use that yeah yet
may come so you can shave it
that's the sides in the back but it
needs to be wet and then uniform but
like I still think we need you need
something exciting to be doing may have
natural for eight years yes I thought
you can't just ride off that we haven't
actually can we introduce the fact that
you're growing a top not to the people
of absolutely podcast world yeah so
Pakistan one cast land we mean wisdom
mean me and Yusef decided that Johnny
needed just a little bit more edge so
the the bottling the theory behind this
or the the basis that this was coming
from
I think that's I'll let you I'll let you
conceptualize so so I write to start
with I have a friend because I'm too
close to the mic you've lived in but
it's at the correct distance over okay I
have two friends and that I believe are
equally attractive but on different ends
of the mail autism spectrum so Chris is
the two ends of the attractiveness
spectrum okay so Chris and wait to say
autism is just another spectrum isn't it
so you know say Chris is autistic
actually I think car isn't David
probably on the same end of the autism
spectrum
well I'll leave that up to you guys
anyway both equally attractive but Chris
is very symmetrical chiseled muscular
that kind of sport sports gear look and
David is very gap years silk kimono lip
ring that kind of look but so both of
them despite being on both ends of the
spot fashion spectrum both gave me a
series of fashion pointers that aligned
and you think well if two people with
good fashion sense but on different ends
agree on that then it must be quite a
good piece of advice because can you
give us very the the recommendations
that were given to you so burn the green
high tops I mean food for me I'm a low
hanging fruit for fashion advice
it was there's so much to be made right
so quickly exactly it's like easy
pickings but burn green high tops get
rid of all of your purple cardigans all
15 of them are in corduroy yeah
grow a beard get a skin faith in a nose
stud or a nose ring for an tattoo done
your pronunciation of corduroy is so
precise you should get ready Marks &
Spencer corduroy called you called your
roy corduroy is that what it is I think
so I thought was quarter or I thought
corduroy is well but I think if we keep
prancing it correct if we've got you on
something I'm gonna be really satisfied
after Paragon pariahs being racist just
cuz I'm Arab yeah anyway so Roy in the
mic is Rochelle podcast number 67
program fitness it was saying it was the
he was the founder of our PE and I was
very pirate about it so anyway
Chris's observation and David of Johnny
is that he's very Abercrombie very
Hollister from top to bottom very
clean-cut square head symmetrical
haircut just jeans and jumper love Navy
lot of thin knit long sleeve tops which
is fine but it's all together it's too
much because because Johnny is
clean-shaven square everything's to
clean and so they need one thing just to
take the edge off
would it provide some added edge yeah
which in the unanimous case was a top
knot so don't make David advised in the
top masseur I think David agrees with me
and Chris well I we were idea Jen we
live we did the brand generation for it
mm-hm and then I think David David David
Isaac maybe came he came in as a
consultant Denis in his elfin pants and
I think you said put down if ukulele
he's still annoyed me for not explaining
to you that so Chris came rod David had
a girl in his room and we heard guitar
playing from the through the room the
next morning David our Chris was there I
was like yeah oh God
text him now and tell her he would
because it looks like he's just had this
girl Robert oh yeah just to see my
guitars yeah I do my vibes yeah you want
you throw a straw hat it flops listen
like it's just straight from Thailand
yeah yeah you've never heard this live
before Wonder Woman oh my god yeah so he
was like precipitously like tell Chris
yeah you wanted to track back so yeah we
wanted to get what I liked about the
idea of you having to talk not is
everything else is gonna stay the same
because I he's not going to see their
lives totally open to an overhaul well
no no you would you were really really
reluctant the reason is moral hazard do
you think that this is it do you think
the top it's a gateway drug
so I think I feel like you can have to
explain moral hazard okay so it's it
this you would experience absolutely no
downside if it was terrible was it you
would you upside of amusement but you
only have upside to gain I have not only
live with it not only the journey of
growing hair long enough to
in a mini ponytail on top of my head
while simultaneously keeping the sides
and back of my hair very short if it
looks [ __ ]
bime up so there's the time in the
middle where it's going to look [ __ ]
regardless you've said that it's looking
better if it looks [ __ ] at the end then
util find it a hillarious I imagine and
I'm like [ __ ] same enough to go the hair
for you I think you need enough faith in
us as friends that we would tell you if
it was her own to that point here we are
yeah how long has it been since you've
at the top of your haircut
twelve weeks that's a long time I mean
you must have had it really short but
folks it doesn't look at that much long
it's just because divots like slick yeah
so it's case it is longer than the side
when I wake up in the center of my head
is just Bob's head
yeah which is prohibitive because I used
to be able to wake up not look like
[ __ ] Hey Arnold do something a half
did it backwards I can't even I go like
to the petros that late you know it you
sometimes mean what in case people see
you well just because people got [ __ ]
there's a difference between being like
careful about your image and other are
wanting to scatter but I said I'll send
you a photo okay
that's something further oh yeah so
you've agreed to get the top nut hmm
which i think is if you if you want to
take me shopping
I'll happen to go fine but it was a
great decision what was the what was the
response because your girlfriend is so
I'd class her as like it sort of breathe
straight up and down kind of not super
edgy girl hmm and she's almost the
female version of how Johnny dresses but
I think slightly more edgy she's a lot
more into fashion than I am when I don't
really care but still like you know
chart accountant yeah like yeah it's
fairly fairly sort straight like she's
not just come back from from Thailand
yeah exactly so running like a yoga
retreat or something yeah yeah um and I
think what you thought was gonna happen
when me and Yusef suggested that you get
a topknot was that you were conceived
Lee oh and straight up my nose you were
Bo's not gonna end up with them with
support for the counter case from your
girlfriend so you could even bring that
back to us and be like oh yeah what
actually happened when you suggested
getting a topknot to a girl who you
thought was gonna say unequivocably so
no she said I really like topknots
why didn't you get a tattoo she was
worth so it was not only yes I agree but
goes to go a bit further do you do
something even more pin how shocked or
even that happened I think just
disbelief so so the first thing I
thought was
something's going on here like they've
spoken to her like honestly that's what
I thought I was like there's a Kristen
use of a front run yeah back here yeah
yeah
it's right there was there's a few lines
of defense so like I asked a few other
people and like generally the response
was like yeah one go for it I asked
David I've proven to expected him to say
yes my last line of defense was a
hairdresser ask my hairdresser who was
like initially he was like he's joking
and then when I was like no no I'm being
serious
two of my friends have suggested it she
then said which two it should initially
she was like resisting resisting which
two of your friends I was like business
partner and I think he has to have my
best interests at heart
because if I do something really stupid
and then we look silly on video on the
internet directly affects his revenue
yeah and I said the other the other guy
is called Chris Williamson she started
blushing and they just immediately
agreed is that she opened it to the
table in rumors yeah so then and then
like the rest of the hairdresser's is
like chipping in crowdsource data and
then she was that everyone's getting
excited about teaching me how to put my
hair in a bobble and Becca's brother
interestingly his had a top knot okay so
speaking to him about what it's like he
said at the top now he would have kept
it his girlfriend didn't like it he said
the worst thing about it is it's hard to
fit all of your hair into the bunt it's
grown on mobile you have to like clip
clip bits
grow longer I mean this is you know it's
a couple football part the gin right so
um we're gonna talk about confidence
today kind of carries on from that ain't
no kind of a roundabout way I suppose so
I don't really I don't really get this
is I'm kind of handling the table over
to you you guys a little bit here
because I think we want to talk with you
on this I think you've been pushing this
topic for a little I think if we keep on
missing it I think it's what everybody
would like to have I think even people
who are confident often don't think
they're confident they impostor syndrome
yes because I think right for someone
who is truly confident that usually well
if they come across confident usually if
they ask them that deep down is a is an
insecurity that they think is forefront
of their personality but everyone else
just sees confidence yeah well I think
it's the people who are
holy unconfident that have the most
brush yeah forthcoming yeah like in a
compensator II yeah like I need to wear
this front to appear confident
interesting because I got a miniature
book from school of life if you follow
me on instagram you'll see that a lot of
the time I quote stuff by Alain de
Botton who is the philosopher and the
guy behind school of life unbelievable
YouTube channel you should check out and
I bought the smallest book I think you
could buy 79 pages and type like font
size 20 this is like it's just it's more
it's just a very very small very thin
button it's twelve confidence and it
goes through a number of the elements he
thinks in the modern world that
contribute to somebody's confidence and
the number one what appears to be the
prevailing element is that people who
are confident do not have dude they
don't hold themselves with too much
dignity so I saw his video on it last
night actually after your recommendation
it was my capture process and I watched
it last night and yeah it talks about I
think was it Erasmus or yep so yeah who
says that we have to embrace our folly
and our ridiculousness and realize the
appraiser folly is the UH in praise of
folly there we go you're very good at
that ok embracing silliness yeah so I
think not he was saying like we all as
soon as we recognize that and we stop
holding ourselves to the standards of
our strengths and we realized that if
you if you're in a foreign country and
you ask some of interactions thinking
that you're gonna get shot down because
they've got a pretty silly tourists yeah
and you just accept that that's the case
anyway then it's a pleasant surprise if
you do is it's quite stoic which kind of
makes sense but I think if you focus
your attention way too much on how silly
and crap you are as Brits we're already
very good at the heart I think yeah and
so the tendency then is to become so
self-deprecating that it almost becomes
a reality or a truth and we know that
the you know
to try and say this in the least
esoteric terms of like what you focus on
becomes your reality man but like the
reticular activating system in your
brain will seek patterns in the sense
that even if you listening right now if
you look around in your room for
anything red suddenly your brain tunes
into all red items and tombs are
everything else and if you close your
eyes and then say right tell me what
things in your room were blue you tuned
up to them you didn't notice them
because they'd already you were focusing
on something else and so is this like
the sake think of something you're
grateful for argument you know like you
know like the gratitude journal is if
you are focusing on being grateful then
you can't be anxious or I definitely
know that boy this is a little bit of a
departure but the doing gratitude
journal is only doing it for the first
time this year and the only way I've
been able to do it is by buying one that
only requires three minutes on the
morning and three minutes at night you
thought the palm off of the five minute
journal I did it's called the six minute
diary absolutely of how someone hasn't
gone cease and desist letter like so
yeah and doing that man like today in
the Jimmy is a perfect example so in the
gym today was talking to another one of
the guys that trains he said that you
had a lot of sleep and yet another bunch
of other stuff that meant he was new to
keen about wasn't feeling very confident
about how his session was going to go
what I said was well you can flip that
on its head and you can think right I
have the opportunity today to do a
training session and test myself when I
wonder prepared on a moonless night when
I'm under reading okay how do I perform
the dirtiest you're a baseline of with
just Peter in the service situation on
it's heading say okay what I saw as a
weakness is actually an opportunity this
isn't this hasn't been optimal in terms
of preparation however I can go into
this and think right well how can I use
that to my advantage right well maybe if
I've got competition and I go in with a
little bit flu or I go me the whatever
it is I know that I can still
work to a very high degree capacity yeah
that doesn't really tie back to the
confidence thing too much for it so I
think the other work that I think that
breeds confidence I think the more that
you the more that you show yourself that
you're able to complete something in
spite of not feeling like you want to
yeah
the more you just settle into this it
becomes a lifeline regardless I think
positivity and you know you can run a
[ __ ] bird we can turn talking to be
blue in the face about the power of
positivity and stuff like that but the
bottom line is that your thoughts end up
becoming an echo chamber for more
thoughts as far as I'm concerned and
momentum is a really really big deal
like catastrophic thinking in the spiral
down is often a lot easier than the
journey up so let me speak but the the
analogy would be you build bricks one on
top of the other right so like I think
we have to define it as well because the
the English language is quite clumsy
with the word confidence in there what
does confidence mean as a union because
to say I don't feel confident in my
session is very different to someone
being a confident person which would be
the lack of social anxiety in that case
and I think it there's multiple
dimensions of it's similar to willpower
or discipline mmm the Steve publican
that came up with six subcategories of
discipline and they don't necessarily
overlap and you could have very good
training discipline we know people that
are really good at hitting the gym six
times a week but they completely lack
discipline in another aspect of their
personality for example so it's one
other thing it's one of the reasons why
I think oh so a lot of people judge like
a an overweight person or someone who's
like poorly dressed I and they
immediately have all sorts of
assumptions on what a person's like but
there that the house might be really
tidy there might be really productive at
work there's research to show that
people judge photos of obese people as
having a certain character going lazy
yep yeah so what does confidence mean to
you in the context that we're talking
about here what does
mean to you in the context that I that I
wanted to pick your brains on it's it's
the the social aspect of confidence
because I think you excel in this
particularly maybe it's part of your
Constitution maybe it's part of your job
and you've had to maintain that and as
we talked about in love Ireland as well
you were very much able to switch it on
when you wanted to I guess that's not
really good that's kind of putting on a
certain mask but yeah there was no hold
back and being on TV for example is the
quickest way to reveal the cracks I
think in someone's shyness do you think
it's the the it's what you know Jordan
Peterson talk when talks about mastery
and saying that it's you do something
and it turns out how you expect
consistently when you when you can do
that than you you could say you've
mastered something it's the world it's
the world appearing the way that you
planned it to be is it not something
along those lines
it's mastery is a prediction of the
world coming true yeah it's a prediction
of the world to the entry or says the
opposite yeah yeah yeah so like you
think you'll get a promotion you get a
promotion promotion you think you'll end
up in a relationship you want to get
married then it all works out yeah so I
think so that's estimation of ability in
a certain well I thank you yet
accurately predicting can you be
confident without that occurring though
because you could this people they were
confident and then don't end up
achieving and just have got blind
confidence incident so I think yeah I
suppose yeah and then Trump who maybe
didn't have the like you might not have
the technical competence but as a result
of your belief you almost fudge people
it will fool people into it will fool
the world into reacting a certain way
because of the veneer that so itself
belief is not suppose rather than
related to an outcome it's like even if
because even if you think like I'm class
at football I'm terrible at football if
I really believe I'm really confident
I've crossed a football doesn't really
matter what happens to her because I
just continue being confident that I'm
good at football yeah so that's
delusional that's the definition yeah
it's a single belief that has held in
the face of any evidence but is that not
of the country because that still the
confidence that
I think it's the question I suppose it
can't because just divisional
confidences I am so I guess what JP say
like the confidence that is grounded in
reality versus listen to this it's so
much my hips are really tight i rom
Wadud today as well to do I just trained
and I know you did I saw you
um so yeah it's interesting I think
I think that you can look at confidence
as in first I you guys seem to think
that I'm some sort of Paragon the pariah
I'm here for I am I Amaya Bastian I
think Europe no I know but I think it's
of confidence I for me I I really really
don't think that I am and I think that
the big capacity for someone to play the
game so to speak of being confident or
being out and I think that you can
actually quite easily conflate
confidence with being extroverted
because you can play it being
extroverted very briefly in short stints
we set this on the livonian podcast you
have on the front Norva I'm on the front
door of a nightclub and that can do a 1
rep max 20-second max effort burst of
train and then over the years you've
increased you what capacity of that
progressive overload not 200 night 200 a
night there maybe 30 second enjoy these
push-ups it was not reduce is that how
you see it them because I honestly think
you are the crouton of confidence like
soups increase yeah exactly
so then is that just like to this is
sort of thing where I believe you that's
the Croatians like the technology of
crouton describe this is exactly what we
think all the time
Edwardian term so when you if you were
to go tonight if we were going to a like
a big event there's gonna be the loads
of people there yeah lots of networking
let's say without alcohol
okay the sake of it lots of just
speaking to people you've never met
before
yeah with this does the prospect of that
make you feel anxious no not at all no
so I think that's daddy's confidence in
that setting which i think is what I
feel not enough that's like saying you
go into a gym are you weak no I'm not
weak therefore you are strong okay
that's not that's not the case there's
like situation-specific or even you go
into a powerlifting needs
in the Northeast compared to Wells I
mean I mean more than what you're saying
is that you are not something which
isn't what we're talking about the Apfel
you are visiting I'm talking about yeah
it's not unless they're opposites but
confidence is the absence of anxiety or
in a certain situation okay so in that
case to that degree yeah one of the
things that I wanted to try and get
across I was thinking about how to how
to explain this
during the podcast and certainly up
until probably about love island maybe a
little bit after that my confidence was
mostly born of my profession being a
club promoter having to deal with people
who were super super high-energy and you
kind of need to match that or else you
get washed away you need to make a name
for yourself with social media and stuff
like that people confront all the time
like can front as in fronting not
conference so it's so true actually you
see people that give it the big inin
talk you'll have all the talk on written
for social media and they see them in
person and they can totally do VI yeah
that's what I love now so I love
challenging people like that and I think
again one of the main things and I said
it on the island it was that honor that
I said it on the podcast about love
island it was one of my concluding
thoughts was that speaking the truth for
me
sounds like a jvp sermon all over again
but speaking the truth for me was the
one thing that liberated me from feeling
from any remaining feelings of
confidence and the fact the matter is
that if you tell the truth in any given
situation with regards to confidence
you're kind of bulletproof from anyone
calling you out up feet from you feeling
silly about anything as if there's Marc
Munson and Portmore approach of like
what Mark Martin saying vulnerability is
strength because if you can be fully
vulnerable they even telling a joke that
might not be well received in a social
situation is expressing your
vulnerability because you're hanging
yourself out to dry potentially yeah and
then other people are the ones that
decide whether absolute values it's a
very endearing quality as well I think
one of the one of the main things that I
wish that I'd known a little while ago
especially with regards to confidence
was the confidence and strength and not
two of the same things like showing that
you're this indomitable spirit
who never gets swayed and never doubts
himself and stuff like that that's not
necessarily confidence
confidence is telling people exactly how
you do feel about things so over the
last three years I've made a conscious
effort to try and be more forthcoming
when I do have doubts about myself
specifically through social media it's a
platform that I've got where I can speak
to more people more quickly than doing
it to whoever's in the office at the
time but even with stuff like that
having having the courage of your
convictions I guess is one of the main
things that has changed for me over the
last three years previously I was able
to play the role of someone who was
confident now you know I only do believe
that I've got a level of confidence that
I haven't ever had before in my life and
I do think that almost all the ties
attributed to the fact that I just don't
care about whether or not someone things
what I say is silly and that is purely
due to the fact that I can tell the
truth because when you start to make up
lies and fibs with little white lies or
keys little pot pies what to try and
polish the way that ya know because then
what happens is the dynamic changes from
someone not liking you to I should have
constructed this situation in a
different manner to make that person
like me and there's this wonderful sense
of liberation when you just speak your
own truth whatever that may be and put
it out there and then okay well that guy
didn't like me well fine like that's
fine exactly sees me I think like I mean
this will have to maybe discuss this in
more detail on the single singleness
you're castin but I know a few people
that got heavily into pickup artistry
they're really technical like oh you've
got to do this thing and then negs them
and then alpha the thing and then and
it's like all it did was sort of two
friends that are really into it and they
both became quite depressed and jaded
with the whole thing because as he said
it made them construct a persona that
was attracted to women it wasn't it was
for 24 hours and then
when they realized who they are it
created more of a divineness though she
actually liked who I really am is so
different to what women would find
attractive that I just feel even worse
about myself but yeah well after yeah I
think so one of the first things that I
think this should not read or hear or
watch like confidence 101 because I
don't I don't understand the vast
majority of the principles behind it we
need to have confidence that you have a
good understanding companies never
ending it either because you have
results to show that you're a confident
person like if you feel like a confident
person or other people think that you're
a confident person chances are cetera
and Ron thinks that he's like confidence
doesn't exist he says there is no such
thing as a stable personality trait
called confidence because if you put
someone in a room on the road
it can't be confident or not confident
did you not put your phone on silent
before this podcast he was confident
that it wouldn't go off can you go turn
off please I'm confident I can stay so
do you think that given what you said
before about being able to put your self
up out on the on the rail I suppose is
seeking advice from other people
where does I fit in can we can we just
stay on the truth thing for gonna come
back different so I know you don't like
him but
garepe j.y his fundamental number one
principle very recently tell us who
carriage awaits
he's a he runs a like a program that is
pretty much geared at helping men who
are successful in other areas of their
life become 4-dimensional as he calls it
so he 30-foot overweight businessmen who
are divorced or failing marriages but a
very rich but maybe haven't got the
other dimensions of their life
okay yeah so what's his core starting
point is to stop lying and to start
telling the truth about like the way
that you feel what you want what's going
on why he feels that people experience a
an unpleasant reality and sid8 away from
what's actually happening under some so
rather than like okay I'm fat my
marriage is [ __ ] I hate my kids my jobs
just this place I go to tune them out
I take loads of drugs so I get drunk on
the weekend it's like just avoiding the
pain rather than that's a very American
things about how are you sir fantastic
thank you very much sir uh-huh yes ma'am
yeah so but what's something that he
talks about because I think the concept
of telling the truth is quite difficult
to get your head around if you read
lying by some Harris no I said to the
list as well man don't be lying and you
want anyone who's listening lying by
some Harris's of one-hour read the
shortest book is written and it is a
conceptual
conceptual justification for why you
should never have a lie ever okay in no
situations now there's a difference
between lying through a mission and
lying through Commission he says that
there are times we're not telling the
full story can be justified right kids
ask about Santa Claus like these new
years old if you lie to them outright
lie to them about it then that trust in
you is going to be reduced however
there's some tact that can be used so
but the restriction of line including
White Lies which are the worst ones as
far as he's concerned that read for
anyone who needs something to get
themselves stuck into it's one hour or
you can audible it one hour and I've
been looking for my next line buy
supplies it yeah yeah he put audio peer
straight via Yemen straight through the
Jordan servers and yeah and so Garrett
White says well so that so he talks
about being being totally honest with
yourself and everyone in your community
as a starting point before you cuz
people try and sort of shoehorn
personal development on top of something
that like their life's just in a minute
if you were to look at so if Maslow's
hierarchy of needs are a hierarchy of
confidence before you can be
outgoing and extroverted you need to
first be secure within yourself yeah and
this is this is this really really cool
quote and I can't and my where it's
coming from I will track it down well it
was reading an article a little while
ago and it was talking about people that
say I am self-conscious a lot of people
that go into social situations
especially if you're introverted can say
I'm very self-conscious but the terms
wholly incorrect and they don't mean
when they say I feel self-conscious they
don't mean that
what they mean is I am conscious of
other people being conscious of me yeah
hmm not conscious of yourself or I'm
worrying about other people's perception
out of me yeah look at the common advice
to fix that is to focus your attention
outwards and you know ask people how
they're doing and rather like stay in
this room a native ballers like saloon
so I think you know to to try and have a
few concrete take away some of the
things that I've done that helped me
with increasing confidence little bit of
stuff that actually crosses off with
pickup artistry if there is anyone who's
listening I want we want to do a couple
of episodes that include pickup ice tree
I'd love to have a guest on him knows
his stuff inside out so RSD max or
anyone like that if you're listening but
all anyone else who's further down the
tree what's the guy who made that wrote
the game Neil Strauss routes to get it
was well I am Manson fine get a lot yeah
well our SD Tyler was we just want to
style a capful as well yeah for sure so
one of the things that they talk about
is power stance adopting a power stance
when you go into a room have you heard
about this yes I did a lecture on this
last week to the power stances that
included part suit so it was saying that
posture is regulated by yeah hormone or
cognitive visual and vestibular control
but the power stance thing is supposed
to so basically where's none look
straight into shoulders right yeah so
the original TED talk and the study was
based on the fact that they made people
go into a Sharma interview standing
apart stands for two minutes and
they measured their saliva cortisol
testosterone ratio and it was higher in
those who stood in the power stance
first what they found later they
repeated the study and there was some
statistical manipulation that went on in
the first one so there's actually no
evidence of hormonal changes but I don't
think we're looking to elicit hormonal
change with the power stance were
looking to change the mental state and
we know that people's ability to believe
their own thoughts positive or negative
about themselves is worse when their
start hunched over looking looking
depressed and when they start more
upright they have more confidence in I
though I'm a lion I'm a worry I'm a lion
I write a suit me because I curl 50
rather than kilos I can I'm alone I can
fight a lion and yeah I mean the whole
first chapter of 12 hours for life is
not a million miles away from this a lot
yeah exactly
what's am I thinking so hormones or not
it does have an effect on your both the
way that people perceive you I mean
that's kind of a good self-evident thing
but also the way that you process your
own thoughts and how much you believe
what is that stuns them just up right
normal stance feet wide apart hands on
hips if you can without looking like a
superhero really has her hips well I
find I find it like when I was doing
when I someone have one foot up on it
like tapped him exactly yeah like I'm
just yeah so definitely when I when I
was playing around with different
tactics for improving my confidence in
social situations that was one of the
things that I used to try and do and
whether it works or not it's on a
hormonal level I'm not sure but it's
just a game about so if this is me Here
I am I don't have really I don't have
anything to worry about I think one of
the main things that you can take away
from confidence is that the desire for
us all to hold onto our own dignity is
one of the key elements of why people
have got lack of confidence
and the problem is that we see everybody
else's lives through an increasingly now
with social media filtered
highlight-reel version yeah yet you see
your own life from the negatives yeah
but you see every you see all the
blunders writen but in the confidence
book I think it might be Erasmus again
as well says something to the effective
in from the hutt Erasmus caramel Rasmus
relations and from the highest to the
lowest we must remember even kings and
princes [ __ ] and you think well the
highlight reel things such a good point
as well because that's people like
editing like selectively editing and
filtering whether it's the absolute best
version of everything it's a worry to be
on social media it's the complete
contrary to the truth as well like
you're not speaking the truth for words
necessarily like you have the
opportunity to lie every point and this
is where you end up with the people that
you have the facade that runs away with
them no hang on like this characters got
away from me so much now that the me who
I am I can't be anymore you know what
does that mean that means that the
person who I was or who I really truly
am isn't good enough and I've got to
play it to this other person new
thinking all the time what would live
Island Chris say what would confident
raise say because Austin yeah
terrified so yeah definitely
definitely need to need to remember the
dignity and a strong grasp on it is not
is not something they should be
concerned about again going back to the
pickup artistry thing one of the one of
the stories that I've heard is if you'll
be the group of friends and then you go
around gonna go and talk to that group
of girls and you get what's called Kay
bead get knocked back I mean from a
group from a group of girls and you come
back over and all of you may also do
that hang on a second
right I want to be even was the only one
that expressed my vulnerability but none
of you either had the [ __ ] courage to
go over there so what does that say
about you like who's got who's got more
confidence the guy that comes back
having been knocked back and has a laugh
about it with the friends because we
have to remember the friends are testing
that person by I think that's it sure I
think it's a show vulnerability on their
side I think it's them going [ __ ]
hell I can't believe he went over and
talked to those girls
I wouldn't dev had the confidence to go
away I must I must therefore cover my
own tracks and pretend that would have
done and had success as well yeah by
drilling someone in it's a bit to have
the confidence in the first place to me
comes from a place of having past
experience of doing something in it
working out quite well but again that
confidence purely based on the results
periences no based on the outcome which
is the wrong way to look at it because
you could go up to a group of girls
every day for the rest of your life to
get KKK be there all the time
hmm so they'll have the confident and
that's confidence it's confidence or is
it because this is the life it's the
lack of attachment to the outcome of
that situation right because that's even
more confident if you've been kb2
a hundred times and you still go and do
it with no fear that's how powers are
different to me thinking I'm good at
football and being terrible so I suppose
the being kebede for the hundred and one
time engine first is not it can be
independent of you'll believe about
yourself it could just be the I say not
fear but you so it's like it's the
confidence to I'm going to do this
regardless of whether it works well or
not it's a hard one isn't it
yeah it's a 10 it's hard to define his
confidence the is confidence actually in
that scenario resilience - it goes badly
but that doesn't affect my it's lucky to
do this guess it's a lack of attachment
to whether or not goes well mmm that the
what's the is it the four the four
precepts are the four principles that
son Miguel Ruiz yeah and is one of them
that anyone's judgment of you is it
don't ever is it don't ever judge
somebody on have you got this in your
Schoen book I think so right what one of
them one of them is established for
agreements yes the four agree me hurts
it and one of them is essentially
something along the lines of he getting
it up yeah if he goes I'm gonna butcher
it if I try and yeah what it's the third
it's the third one I think be impeccable
with your word don't take anything
personally that's it that's the one
don't take anything personally have you
gotten a lot if you got a summary of it
like for the second one there's a
Winston Churchill quote which is
successes to move from failure to
failure without loss of enthusiasm yeah
Charlie's fantastic we're going to cool
to me that's what that is it's like I'm
just going to follow that with this
follow through with this approach well
the document that don't take anything
personally when we're talking about the
social situation is exactly correct
there so the an analogy would be we keep
on going back to to relationship so it's
the easiest one but let's talk about you
so you go in it to a friend let's say
you want to make friends you're in a new
city mm-hmm
yeah I've never been here before and you
go up to a group of similar aged guys
and you think I want these guys are
dressed similar to me in a similar age
to me and maybe they've got similar
interests so you go up and you try and
have a conversation with them and they
all sort of turn around and look at you
weirdly and don't really reply and
mumble something in you have to shuffle
off and it was all a bit awkward but you
don't know what's just happened those
guys could have literally just come from
a wake mmm what if they're duds could
have just died someone could have just
split with one of you it was fine go at
it like wow they didn't like me but no
yeah one of them's just found out
they've got terminal illness or anything
could have happened
and you could go back three weeks later
and that same group of people could be
in a different mindset something else
could have been might not have happened
and so that's like staying positive
about a situation like something that
goes badly and instead of thinking oh
how I'm a piece of [ __ ] like I'm
worthless you feel you know what
actually probably nothing to do with me
it's like taking anything and just
thinking it's fine anyway yeah well if
and again with that the only armor that
you have to wear in that situation is
speaking the truth because if you do
anything short of speaking truth then
you have you've cultivated the
you've put forward and you pruned it in
a manner that became elective and that
decision in which direction that you go
affected the outcome and that gives you
cause to think twice about stuff because
you like hang on what if I'd said this
instead of that wife had said hasn't
said this message izing rather than just
saying like this is who I am
it's out of my control whether people
respond negatively or positively need a
sponsor
and yes I guess that so I I have quite a
unorthodox view of the sir I believe
desire precedes the feeling which
precedes the thought as a moment as
opposed to the typical paradigm which is
the other way around so I I think that
your core desires so the wanting of
approval control and safety give rise to
so they're like the trunks of the tree
which is the analogy they use give rise
to the emotions which stem from wanting
approval controller safety and if those
things are challenged and then they
create they provide the soil for the
thoughts to come out of mixing analogies
but basically tree trunk desires tree
branches emotions leaves or thoughts
okay and so for example I used to be
very nervous on camera because Johnny
and I started prepping Fitness as a
written blog and we were just writing
articles and then suddenly we were like
are Seyfried is greener
safe - green we were just keyboard
warriors that didn't lift it yeah but
then we were like okay you know the
first step is you put up a topless photo
online it's a little bit scary
especially when people are looking at it
in the office and so on then it was like
right me to do podcasts and videos first
time I did a video
I remember being petrified had to
rerecord twenty-five times and any
little stumble up oh no I'm gonna edit
it out and stuff for you rerecord and
over time I think just from a purely
evolutionary or physiological basis that
you you apply repeated scary stimuli
even less sensitive to them and now
there's no fear to doing video you know
that thing's like a live video where you
see the little green light am i right
15,000 people you're on if you [ __ ] up
like that's it you just have to roll
with it yeah and I remember that being
really scary but
what's happened is on a neurochemical
basis you're less reactive to that scary
stimulus and then as a result your mind
starts then justifying more positive for
patterns which are you know what it
doesn't matter it's natural everyone
messes up everyone stumbles over things
or whatever it is that you're you might
so it's not that you changed your
thoughts and therefore you became us
fearful mmm it's that you change the
feeling and then your thoughts about the
subject changed as a result yes early I
really loved the concept I remember
feeling like you saying first few videos
like oh my god what if this goes wrong
yeah
and now if something goes wrong my first
thought what usually is like if anyone
takes the piss like you do it you do a
live video good but like it's again with
that that so this comes back to the
thing about the vulnerability a little
bit that I think a lot of the time
confidence is confused with strength or
a lack of vulnerability and that's
totally not true that vulnerability and
this is to anyone who wants to own
anyone who's struggling to make friends
one of the best things that you can do
is show you the realities and not you
strengths to people because
vulnerabilities are so endearing and
strengths just make you look like a
well-to-do [ __ ] yeah in that study that
we we talked about in the last one of
the professor that gave a speech and a
classroom of people and they ran it
twice the split test a bit only
difference was at the start of one of
them the professor dropped the papers on
the floor but when people rated them
liking the second professor much more
than just you guys more honest yeah the
vulnerability is such a big deal and
that's the same if something goes wrong
you know previously when we were first
doing these podcasts are aware that this
is only you know into the teens of the
episodes now but the very very start I
would be hyper hyper concerned about
whether or not something something was a
blender or something messed up but
that's just a much a part of the
character is anything else obviously if
it was five minutes of the Bibbit
that would be a little bit silly this is
your post hoc rationalization now yeah
whereas if you had a blunder in episode
of wine you'd be thinking or but now
like because the feelings changed your
brain produces different thoughts about
the subject but maybe it rationalizes it
as are you know what people are just
thing in their car they're not going to
care about a couple of seconds of mood
yeah whatever
so I but again it just it adds character
do you not I mean it's it all comes back
for me it all comes back to speaking the
truth that if you're perfectly happy
with what it is that you're putting
forward the person the truth that you're
speaking in a person you are being
forward so what like it doesn't matter
but again if you were oh well I was
trying to play the role of X that made
me blunder [ __ ]
maybe if I'd tried to do the role of Y
that wouldn't it make me blunder because
this it becomes it becomes discerning
rather than just sort of like a straight
line there's a there's really the
protection from that as well though like
oh at least I wasn't showing the true me
and it was just the the mask that got
knocked down yeah but I mean that's
that's such a health it's such a false
economy that like the the level of
indestructible nuts that you have or
invincibility the of as a person being
truthfully and honestly yourself and
trying to be as close to virtuous as
possible is it's unbeatable absolutely
unbeatable counterintuitive isn't it but
yeah
do you think there's any scenarios so
something that the Garrick Garry's is an
example when he decided like I'm just
gonna be totally honest about everything
he's in the he's buying something in a
shop standing at the tail and the lady
goes how's your day sir
he was a [ __ ] [ __ ] like [ __ ]
terrible I've had a [ __ ] day and like
he's just just says exactly what's on
his mind
and uses it uses the he has this the
caveat is like honesty is best used when
it's relevant to a situation like if
you're walking along the street you're
[ __ ] fast was it really weird oh yeah
but technically you're telling the truth
you being honest we all roll and
relevant yep yeah so there's a say so is
there is there any situate like well I
think what I'm trying get across is I
think saying to someone who has no
context just tell the truth
yeah that there has to be a lens with
which I sprayed otherwise it's like
turnout sometimes you can add is having
a much worse experience of life I mean
we brushed on autism other oddities yeah
I mean I think yeah you are right you
need to curate whatever it is that
you're doing I think that you can curate
your
you can create your projection whilst
not editing your persona for people so
was it moved in the delivery yeah yeah
like when I'm the way that the way that
I talk to people on the front doors and
I am you're a bit overweight rather like
you've said about the referentially
looking back with this level of
perspective on things that you can you
knock something else no should you like
to soar on my knees getting swollen is
it so this is healthy toes going bleep
whatever Blitzer I've got I just got
that circulation as long as you're
confident I'll be okay
it will be well then it's a truthful
thumb thumb big toes and firm is very
similar on flip them and so you have
both read or listened to his dark
materials on you mm-hm
there's this concept in that which keeps
on coming up anyone who hasn't it's a
series of books by Philip Pullman they
butchered it when they tried to turn the
first one into a film out here Northern
Lights
I don't even seen them yeah it was
watched half of it was a very horrible
can sleeping that was a massive fun the
book mmm
book said I think we all were it just
really like Disney find it in most [ __ ]
it was so [ __ ] considering how brilliant
that book series we're so anyway it's a
it's a fantasy novel series three books
long and in it this this girl finds that
she's able to do something naturally
that it's incredibly rare then as she
comes of age in puberty she finds that
she loses the skill and during this
conversation with a kind of likely the
head matron of this particular
discipline she talks about this journey
through unconscious grace to conscious
onion grace to conscious grace and this
a lot of the time it is what I feel like
the journey through confidence can be
like that people may naturally have a
particular capacity within a social
situation hmm then a few situations to
occur that make me think holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's a lot on the line here
people can think I'm silly and this than
the other they become conscious they
lose the the skill they lose the talent
and then the woman says it in the book
she says it will take you a lifetime to
learn what your depth of understanding
will be infinitely greater than it ever
was before
mmm and I think that that with regards
to a lot of pursuits there to do with
social skill is exactly what happens so
for instance I remember this is not like
that by remember I was about five years
old running and somersaulting off a
diving board on holiday because I had
absolutely no concept of theater mmm
then I remember being about 10 or 11
when it started swimming properly and
hood clunk my head off the side of a
swimming pool a few times and thought
[ __ ] well no we're on the diving
board
but you're yeah from what have a variety
of accidents it oh it's not something is
so painful and thinking this [ __ ] no
way you're gonna get me running wise I
slip what if I did this to any other and
they think oh okay I now need to retrain
myself to have this conscious grace hmm
and it's the it's that reflex from a
little bit of trauma mm-hmm that can
break down someone's natural capacity to
do things it's trading like we talked
about last time yeah exactly that yeah
yeah you know you said the best traders
are often the newest traders are often
the best ones I can go lucky attitude
and they just yeah they're traders they
feel rather than obsessing over every
miner so you're now trying to get back
to the same state of mind you're in when
I feel audited yeah I'm in conscious and
grace right now and then yeah speaking
of diving boards I don't know if you
ever jumped off like that the really
high one mm-hmm it's never a bore form
oh I remember like it's like a proper
slap in the ball sack like if you had
feet are even slightly apart yeah I
think after that I was like I did I did
you know I speak anyone here in the nuts
yeah
I mean if there's anything they'll take
the window it's you know jet isn't it
weird
the sloped roads that connected house
are helpful you hit the bottom if you'll
stick right if you understand the
physiological response of being kicked
in the mats please tweet me so that we
can understand it for the next one might
require multiple tweets but things like
doing do it he's already signed it
so the there'll be a referred pain now
them and I think like so for if you have
air under the diaphragm or liver
swelling you can get shoulder tip pain
because the same nerve that innervates
the diaphragm also innovates the skin at
the tip of the shoulder that's
interesting the Wyatt like TD to
experience in order you get kicked in
the balls I haven't been kicked in the
balls for ages when was the last time
you got kicked in the nose be a long
time either I have a memory of someone
swimming beneath me and coming up like
that head intervals and I was like I get
out the pool that's it and you're like
and yeah what's in the head what was
happening um he was a bit drunk and
didn't like the McCrory was going rear
ended up head broke your charging hands
you don't just go yeah so yeah is there
anything else yeah so I think for me
there was it was a time in my life when
I remember feeling very unconfident and
then a phase where I feel like I'm quite
confident now and I think for me that's
so that's going from being chubby kid to
you it's being seen as the person who's
like Johnny's massive it goes the gym or
sort of stuff and so for me I think
strength training has always been
something that's allowed me to build my
confidence in like a very like contained
way because you have a series of
experiences which is like I can't do
that I've done it all that didn't go
very well
but I've succeeded anyway and it just
it's just a series so that's you've
touched on two separate elements there
one of them is about your intrinsic some
tasses which are meaningful to you yeah
the other one was
with other people's possess yeah now if
anyone is trying to rely get their
confidence to rely on other people's
perceptions of them mmm you building a
house I'm very very shaky from - I agree
I agree but I think for a lot of people
so a lot of that a lot of people I know
who I would concede to be confident
strength train so that's a really
interesting thing as well because if
somebody I think the strength training
is the initial precipitant to gaining
confidence yet then it depends from that
point how much it hinges on that by how
much long ago identity it or not yeah so
you have like the the power lifter who
you know that you like has all the all
the gear and you know really know invest
the right yeah their identity in you
know the bald beard like top know a
little life and really invest the rest
he has like there's a power lifter and
then if they have an injury or whatever
and they can't do that thing yeah it can
go one of two ways it can either be that
they've they've built up their
confidence and it's ratcheted up and
they've leveraged laughs yeah they've
proved to themselves that they have
competence to then expand to other
things or they invested so heavily in
that identity that and I think might
even Eric Helms actually or someone said
to hey I was there it comes in had your
identity across multiple things so that
he was like I'm not always gonna be a
bodybuilder yeah and you know at some
point I'm gonna be old and fat so if I
need to add value another area hafta
yeah otherwise if I just go Bulls in on
the time it's it's like I am Johnny and
I power lift versus I'm Johnny the power
lifter yeah a two very different reality
that's why that's why I like the idea of
the top not for you catches my
personality no it's the yellow card off
but it's because it makes you more of an
enigma it's look at all of these things
so well well-written well-spoken
well-educated chart accountant but then
also able to pick up three hundred and
ten kilos [ __ ] he's got top Knoxville
yeah
great this like oh my god yeah
just game paddle - with so this I don't
think we've actually even touched on
another Don Miguel Ruiz then don't allow
people to put you in a box
don't be categorizable you know I think
rate your box I think behavior I think
being multifaceted and so some people
are by their very nature of within a
cookie cutter mold young people have to
fall within that yeah um I really want
to do this is quite a nice and positive
one for me because of my natural
temperament
I wasn't that loved and that was largely
yeah I've got depressive personality
sometimes and one of the things that I
really really want to do a podcast on is
why worth it to be lonely which is a
YouTube video done by Alain de Botton
from school of life and as a part of
that one of the things he says it's at
the most subtle and at the most subtle
and unique but the most sort of mindful
your views are the fewer people are
going to be like you in society and
given the choice between honesty and
acceptability most of us understandably
choose the latter but again with that if
you have this multifaceted slightly
country slightly subtle different
worldview presuming that it's not going
to offend anyone I get you in jail might
be an idea to try and speak it forth
because it will open up some other
people's eyes and specially the internet
you will find people that resonate with
you said Leo Kardos tiny but he loved
you they rate you people who love you it
polarizes opinion one of the things we
haven't really touched on yeah I don't
think at all in this I think that
podcast we started doing lot of wisdom
post in the pulse jbp world and so
Jordan Peterson who's being a guiding
force for me in understanding myself and
I think you guys too degree as well one
of the key one of the key habits that
you asks people to cultivate to clean up
the room and what he says is that lemme
help clean your room I mean feces
these kids that they're eighteen and
they want to go out and change the world
but how can you apply about the economic
state of the world when you can't even
clean your room so what he says this boy
says is that your bedroom is a domain of
competence within everybody's capacity
so everyone can clean that room like
unless you're one of the people with
those people out of like hoarders like
you can clean your room you could have a
disability okay people a large majority
of people can clean their room and more
widely blind Thanks well that's
offensive to blind people who can't
clean that room no cuz they're gonna say
well I'm glad you said fine to be might
be blind I didn't say blind people can't
clean their room were you applied that
and they say my duplication is a very
personal thing what you've taken is my
appreciation might not be what I apply
I'm responsible for what I say this time
I choose my words very carefully very
very very precise but you saw that with
busy that something the WEP yeah that
was brave yeah as you know like I have
mixed feelings about him but things like
that brilliant I think what you eat I
think you're a few mixed feelings about
your piece and before you read his book
yeah talk for me as well it's been
really difficult going anyway so you
thought you talks about your bedroom is
a domain of competence and once you've
mastered that you can then look to
expert okay so what else can I clean up
kitchen maybe I can go kitchen maybe I
can go into the living room maybe I can
help someone else with that bedroom or
their problems or whatever it might be
and it's starting in a domain that is a
safe space so to speak it's something
that you know that you can get mastery
over pretty quickly and you build a
brick on top of that and the power
lifting analogy that you use for
yourself seems a little bit like that
it's a domain of competence that you are
capable within not obviously it's by
virtue of gravity it can be quite hard
gets progressively harder so it renders
the thing it you know because you you
put more weight on which to me seems
he picked it up wait why pick it up yeah
now you've already done it my car
doesn't it was hard and then you put
more weight on me pickup because
sometimes I have to get more than one
time that seems almost pointless yeah
ridiculous cuz you put it down in the
same place every single time and pick it
up in exactly the same way yeah I think
that so that creates certainly you
almost witness it like we see with our
clients so you they all come
different people so much because of the
muscle mass it's because of you said
they've proven to themselves that they
can be competent in something and they
extrapolate that to other yeah go from
like I'm overweight I don't like how I
look - like oh my god I have I'll a
sativa I've done this yeah I look
totally different what else can I do
yeah so a self belief I think run your
self efficacy is mmhmm yeah that is true
like I've done what I said I well how
does how does that manifest itself
moving forward in confidence confidence
is the meta term that I think it's just
it's just believing that you can go do
tonight with change because it
essentially yeah so that's the same as
like you go into a job interview and you
think I'm gonna do well here rather than
I'm not worth the job and someone who's
like got a gold medal at Worlds probably
probably has quite a lot of like I'll be
alright with that yeah this is someone
who's like never tested their physical
abilities or push themselves outside the
comfort zone I'm sure that there must be
people who are potentially not on the
physical side but cerebrally testing
themselves very heavily yeah
someone who's studying for a crazy
research degree or whatever it might be
and these people are overcoming
obstacles in a similar manner
mhm well so I was gonna say there's a
lot there's a high suicide rate in
Cambridge University for example of
people who like and they tend to be the
higher highest performers that are so
hard on themselves for not living up to
high star instant up here yeah I don't
know what's going on there
I did I did an Instagram post that was
that concluded with something along the
lines of the line between self
motivation and self compassion is a lot
wider than you think
and I think that a lot of the time
people can confuse being compassionate
with themselves with not having drive to
be better mmm so allowing yourself to
you had confidence to go into a
situation that situation didn't turn out
the way that you wanted okay
how should I then tree discipline myself
after this situations occurred oh
absolutely yeah if I don't beat myself
up then how am I gonna I'm not where I
learn I'm gonna think that like this was
an acceptable outcome despite the fact
it wasn't the outcome that I wanted
[ __ ] well then nichibei exclusive yeah
the best way the best way to do that and
one of the one of the tactics that I've
been using more recently for this has
been treat treat yourself as if you were
a friend that you're responsible for
helping again another Jordan Pederson
rule and you wouldn't lay into them all
the time you'd be like look here are
your faults it's how you can improve
rather let's make a plan - yeah better
oh absolutely won't ever remind them
every day together take a lot of the
time I'll think like what would you say
if one of your friends came to you with
this particular problem what would you
say to them and you know if you could
say if one of your friends came up to
you and you like you what it just
reminded me of in lifehacks 103 give it
a listen great episode was when Johnny
said sometimes if you have multiple
captures across different things or
you've captured but then you forgot to
review the capture and then it's your
brains way oh yeah yeah no you're paying
for them I have experience in today and
I mean your voice came into my head of I
made a reminder which so I used Siri so
I used like that yeah remind me to it
misinterpreted it the reminder came up
9:00 and next morning look to them like
no idea what it is I mean you always
came to my head was like yeah I need you
to feel worse
like resent me I don't know you have to
remember something out you ever a set
reminder for and I've got no idea what
it is
we can't decipher my words then you get
a call two weeks later from your dentist
being like we're gonna have to discharge
you from our clinic because you know
someone who has a really interesting
perspective on like self management
Jaakko willing yeah yeah he's just so
far over on the like redlining end of
the spectrum of their like his Instagram
every other post on Instagram is his
watch at 4:00 a.m. like 401 4:00 a.m.
359 when he wakes up yeah and then
there's a photo of pool of sweat where
he's been entrained and he just puts the
aftermath and he had a video about like
what to do when things aren't going well
and your life it's like ah you didn't
get that job you feel from broke up with
you like good like your business failed
good you fight now shake good
he's like real oh we hope he's a [ __ ]
good after he's a [ __ ] Navy SEAL yes
up but a part of me thinks like if you
just treat yourself like a drill
sergeant the whole time there's probably
not even time to be like I'm a piece of
weak piece of [ __ ] because you just
already thought about anything you do
burpees in there yeah honey you just
mask it all the time be like what would
Jacov do you know space for like Gary
Gary Vee is a [ __ ] version of chocolate
they're very similar very similar to
subscribe to accept Gary's like just
post on Instagram Gary Vaynerchuk drop
the wings like [ __ ] you get to the gyms
4 a.m.
don't don't press snooze get up you
bastard yeah yeah like I wonder if would
happen if they met don't [ __ ] they
probably agree on a lot of things I
really really hope chuckling punches
anything it's just so irritating so if
you listen to some of the experiences as
a Navy SEAL the Joker's hug you do think
like if you've been in those sorts of
scenarios anything else is just
absolutely in significance like their
Fight Club thing is that like when
you've been in a fight that morning
everything else the rest of the dude has
denied you in town yeah and like I think
there is none tonight but this is one of
the things you can
and expedite life experience hmm to a
degree you can try and cram it in mm-hmm
but there's required time and attention
that you need to do through the
summation to really sink in yeah 100%
because you need it's not just the time
that it takes so just having experience
it's then the reflective period of the
experience then the experience again
with a new a new set of eyes and new
approach do you think that is what
explains the general increase in
people's confidence with age like do you
think it's it because under the Sun
there's time available for those
experiences to be processed or do you
think there's some kind of thing
inherent to aging that causes it no I
think it's that if you have a smaller
sample size something going incredibly
well are incredibly badly
it's more of an outlier then if you then
okay you think you've got more some more
of a casino or before variances though
no here we are again I said I thought I
thought this was a hundred and five
percent greatness actually in 10 years
time I've realized that that wasn't even
a 50% of greatness
so you're just much more so I guess you
become more cynical but also all can bar
things because it's just like wow you
just want measure the same it's being
measured in the same thoughts yeah yeah
it's being measured about experiences
and this is one of the things when
that's very liberating for me personally
is it you know with single guy growing
getting older now as I'm 30 you can walk
into a club and walk into a bar or
whatever it might be and previously you
walk up to a group of like I don't know
you're on you early twenties guys and
previously there'd be this South chest
up dick-measuring kind of what do you do
usually you do it like that kind of
thing and now I'm interested in your
your progression with this it's just
just now it you can kind of have a smug
sense of satisfaction as you get older
it's the one thing that time is the one
thing that we don't get any of it back
it's also the one thing that's you you
can't cheat it either way you can't make
yourself younger and you can't make
yourself older and it means that it's
kind of an idiot of those not of why
I've been using currents from
so they all live all that early I want
of uni so did you use to ever experience
so that that situation walking up to a
group of guys
you said so you wouldn't experience
anxiety per se but it was more of a
massively massive okay and that's and
then the I guess the compensation is
just glass yeah a little bit but you
want used to be I suppose and I yeah I
think I think definitely I was an only
gripe only child which means that your
socialization is very very different to
someone that's got sibling incredibly
different and I think definitely to a
degree it meant that I was probably
slower to socialize and also sorry
sorry more as an experiment and more as
a list of inputs and outputs something
to be mindful of rather than a natural
part of day-to-day discourse because for
me growing up I didn't have that play
lot sports and those would be my
brothers and sisters so to speak mhm
but that a lot of that stuff didn't come
naturally to me so I had to cultivate it
which actually I was you know how far on
the spectrum we all are of like I saw a
social interaction as a series of
endurance of our pets absolutely it is
it is like oh I can't I can't make it
pretense about the fact that it came
naturally to me you think it's autistic
to even think I want to get better at my
ability to socialize no you don't know
do you think so they thought I always
have is like I have this like stock guy
in my head who's like similar age to me
all they care about is like beer and the
football match and like Pop Idol and all
these sorts of things I'm aware that pop
idols see what they did and like
wouldn't wouldn't even consider like
getting an audible account or today does
even cross their mind like I'd like to
improve my ability to socialize with
other people so that's a little
conscious grace thing that there's a
natural like because I think social
intelligence is so independent of normal
intelligence that you can have in you
met people that like you wouldn't cost
them as the brightest tool in the shed
but they're so a grocery of learn and
really engaging and I guess if you if
you make them start like dissecting it
actually is probably gonna take things
apart because again you have yeah Ethan
you know I'm good a good example of this
we're talking about strength sports
dmitriy klokov
mmm-hmm has a very unconventional style
of lifting his feet are too close
together sometimes once in front of the
ergot bowed legs doesn't he yeah he's
just he lifts he lifted a Russian it
does left shooting
in a style when she coach would come
over and say well this is wrong this is
wrong and this is wrong but naturally
he's very capable within the domain of
competence so much you'll snitch yeah oh
so much more
yeah with one arm yeah so yeah it's it's
just some people have this natural
ability but you're right like some
people quite rightly so don't want to
cultivate well they don't have to
systematize it it can just be well no
they just don't want to maybe the bad
socially and they don't care
well maybe the but I have no desire to
get better so is that confidence so that
book yeah because then being passive or
carry actions that is that desirable but
again I think comfort I think confidence
can be broken down to a lack of a lack
of attachment to the outcome of
something so if you are not bothered
about whether or not it goes well it
goes badly you can always explain by
yeah
safety catch on that is that if if
you're bad socially late you're socially
anxious but you don't care about it and
you wouldn't be socially anxious because
the self-correcting mechanism yeah so
but maybe all you care about it's like
Warcraft and I went oh she's anxious all
you're thinking about is Warcraft I feel
like I'm socially anxious but I
generally go home games wait yeah do it
Pepa so done how to become more
confident within warcraft within the
Warcraft and well that's Warhammer sorry
Warcraft is the online online MMORPG oh
my god okay so one more question which
so if you are seeking advice from people
yeah how does that fit into your
definitions of confidence can you
explain wait I'm not really sure Sony so
seeking advice getting a coach though I
don't I don't you mean by that hobbies
not with as a sense of like so if if
self-efficacy and self-assuredness is
all about being comfortable with your
decisions and knowing but how does then
seeking advice from others rapport with
being comfortable what is going on here
it's all about my trochanter isn't that
your birthday
so what are the best as evil as that
cursor is involved yeah you see that a
sack of fluid or someone who manages the
finances of a school okay so I think I
think that when you're talking about
confidence
a admission that you want to better
yourself without feeling silly or
concerned about the process that you're
going to go through is absolutely a part
of that okay because I suppose that even
in seeking advice there's a spectrum of
like being an [ __ ] and just asking
for the sake of it or going out like a
year going overboard asking advice but
not be taking any of it and just using
it as a procrastination tool or asking
so that it confirms your existing users
your confirmation bias or it's totally
well what's the word
unbiased like asking for advice and then
take what some or what's more liberating
than you thinking to yourself okay I
need to get better at X I'm going to ask
a question about it that's not what what
requires more confidence than that so I
think that follow the owner ability to
sit with just by backing yourself that
if you're told to do something like if
if you ask for advice and someone gives
you advice and you trust that person you
like gopher okay so you're like I want
five that's confidence in them right
it's yeah I suppose it's accurately
assessing your so like for example we
were like okay our fashion ability is
quite low we know someone who we act we
can assess it has a more complete
understanding of that house horse yeah
so being objective with yourself as much
as possible I guess so yeah trying to
say where am i weak where am i strong
yeah where can I begin with that that
comes back to being able to be truthful
because one of the problems I had I
played a role for a very very long time
the one that ended up manifesting itself
in love Ireland and oddly enough was
highlighted to myself internally so
starkly that it was what made me realize
right you need to actually try and find
out who the [ __ ] you are because it's
not that person you thought it might
have been but it's definitely definitely
[ __ ] not in three weeks with
cameras on you has made it quite
apparent I think that I spent an awful
lot of time pretending to be something
that I wasn't and that series of lying
meant that I actually didn't know why I
was good and what I wasn't good at now
how was I able to work out where which
elements of my life needed work when
everything was alive the lies and the
fronting and the facade and the veneer
had become so much a part of me
the items are I finished I didn't where
I finished and and and it began so it's
because I mean people are supposed to
have different you know likes you get
you go through set a whole traumatic
experience or protection whatever and
suddenly you're forced to reveal the
true you and for you that was the one
but seriously though like you're like
from us Here I am in this world and I'm
realizing holy [ __ ] the person that I've
been trying to like put out to the world
I can't sustained yeah so there has to
be a gap between love Island Chris and
real Chris yeah and and other people
like already plane crash or you know get
marooned on an island then you went on a
reality TV show that's on the island
it's all the same thing I was on an amaz
marooned and a night is it actually just
an island
it's me Orca alright she's a nice nice
place to be buried that's our new a
marine and what I'm doing today we're
not going to be marooned either anymore
no but only because he has confidence in
you he does on his ability to follow the
advice right anything else any closing
thoughts I think we covered some pretty
good ground in that and I was a lovely
run through earth definitions different
domains of confidence and what you've
done because I think I was excited to do
this episode to see what your evolution
has been and how you see the whole
discipline of confidence being the
person who I think is the the most least
the most confident person that I know
personally
like going to isolate learn exactly well
like so we went to Iceland together the
three of us and I remember just it was
ridiculous like but I suppose like a
club is the is your that's your thirst
Dominic ground that's no good job it's
the same if you were like the guy that
started on you the several nurses
several women flocking [ __ ] to you
late was all quite startling new Iceland
the yeah they tried to get us off his
table in Iceland yeah when we were in
that not that in it was like and he was
like I've but I've bought this bottle
this single it was like alright then you
want to speak I can't remember how well
it was so funny about that looking back
she was I felt a sense of total calm
because I was just like Chris has dealt
with this a million times if it's just
it's just it was a pissed up twenty
two-year-old who'd bought a single
bottle of Smirnoff and thought that that
somehow it gave him right to move me off
his table yeah and then physically try
to push them any doorman the doorman put
is handing the way in between both of us
and said basically sort of I got this
finger in this is obviously a kid who
goes to the club a fair bit and now hey
so the doorman in done that so I put my
hand on his back and I said you just
listen to your dad yet that was it yeah
and oh no you just listen to your boss
and then and then just waited there
finish my drink put my drink back down
on his table and then left oh yeah it
was just a feeling of like trying to
give an example it's like being in a
being in a plane crash but you know the
pilots Connors
it's fast like this is not like that bad
guy has no idea how many times Chris is
dealt with people like him in situations
like this and then at the end it all
worked out fine that is Icelandic many
know different exposures to exposure
it's time and attention right I might I
think that I would like to part with yes
start with something like if you feel
like you're lacking confidence start
with doing trying to do something just
yourself like to make you about example
and prove to yourself that you can
achieve something root yourself that you
can be consistent
something that you set yourself to do
you wonder if the ice-cream plans being
picked up on the mr. could be I'd know I
agree I Greek you hardly find find a
domain of competence
I got start to push it a little bit and
prove prove to yourself that you can't
do something that you maybe don't right
now I don't feel like you can and then
over time as a result of doing that you
become a different person and start to
set the bar slightly higher and slightly
higher until one day you're doing things
that like two years ago we never the
moon a versatile well there's a breeds
constant this point to make it
progressive as well because I think if
you suddenly hold yourself to standards
that are way above your current level
like the Cambridge suicides like you're
only going to fall short of it yeah
as opposed to yeah begin with your
domain a bit and throw the momentum in
import into so this is again another
people just need to remain still more
things become thoughts as opposed to
thoughts become things and it's if you
spend the entire day there's no
difference between the going spends the
entire day ruminating about going to the
gym obsessing listening to a gym
playlist 1 per self up and using of
every ounce of willpower to get herself
to the gym and the girl needs the
thought and the girl who just gets in
the car and then is up at the gym the
only difference is one of them views of
a fuckton of world power and energy
getting that there was something you
said to me this is not really related I
haven't either never know which is
things I've learned from my friends
right like lessons it was something you
said to me it was in the same
conversation where you initially said
that to me
yeah where I was something about my
shoelaces and it was like I was like
it's ok because there's a process
because if I trip on my shoelaces I know
to tighten up and then you said like yes
but if you act on the like if you act on
the react and the result rather than the
economy no it doesn't go down under that
one
it's like when I quoted you at Corey
Allen and you I remember you saying like
because at the time I was being really
inconsistent with my training and you
use that as an example that there's no
like you don't have to make fanfare
about it just just do it get them just
start doing some stuff yeah and the same
thing so I think you're totally right to
begin I think confidence can be
confidence needs to be a belief that
your capacity is greater than what you
think in it or it's greater than what
you believe it to be currently that if
you were presented with a challenge but
there is a fair chance that you may be
able to overcome it yep and if you don't
you will be okay yeah or you'll figure
it out yeah
no matter what happens you know yeah so
I'm going to go at the gym today I'm
gonna try and PR I'm gonna pick up a 315
kilos I didn't pick up between 2 and 15
kilos okay what can we learn from that
yeah so I think begin with the domain of
competence [ __ ] clean e rumor like
Manas leads the single biggest impact
that I've been able to have it's been
making my bed every day and this is a
combination actually of the video of the
naval officer that went high or low you
are cleaning you got a cast mate again
just talked about making it yet and
that's like 50 million views if you
haven't seen it surgical cast I think
it'll come up it's like the first win of
the day on Facebook yeah even nailed
that you've already started today well
write my bed's mate and then the love
them the nicest thing that nice is
footnote easy does and if your day has
been completely [ __ ] and everything's
gone wrong you come home to a made bed
yeah and you're like Judd is yes that is
so I think for me really what I get out
of morning routines training in the
morning or anything like that is a
feeling of confidence it's like I by
9:00 a.m. I've done everything I wanted
to do the chances of me having a good
day to me just how I feel a higher
you're on a roll and even if it goes
[ __ ] you get to the end of the day and
you're like yeah but I'm nail I'm mail
this morning I think for me definitely
as well one of my Keystone habits is
getting up early and then - I'm getting
my morning routine right because the
opposite is true as well
when you see hours yeah when you start
the day badly you frame everything with
in harsh well if I haven't got a if I
hadn't don't miss that any other
everything's jaded with this really
really bad view as opposed to doing it
the other way which is I'm gonna get
after it oh well this didn't go as well
as I thought but I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
gonna have it like I'm gonna I'm gonna
go after this task this situation isn't
beyond my domain of competence or even
if it is
still going to be able to crush it so
yeah wait waking up fairly because even
then like it gets to 3:00 in the
afternoon and you're like I feel a bit
tired and we're gonna hold on like
today's going so well it'd be a shame to
ruin it
yeah I'll just do it I leave the room
and it almost just keeps you in this
little pathway until the end of the day
like what a great day and I can now I
can relax I'm allowed to relax because I
deserve yeah yeah so wake up Dominic
Dominic
don't worry Hamptons it's not your if
start go through Instagram it yeah so
yeah domain of competence start with
something that you know that you can
conquer and then start to push that
progressive overload yeah I think
definitely being prepared to put
yourself into situations that you
wouldn't normally be in without any
preconception of a desire or a
requirement for success or a requirement
for an outcome that you would derive a
success within that to believe it's
successful like just going on a night
out as being in a social yet situation
is take that one off the list like cool
okay I've spent a bit of time and
attention there like I've spent I've
learned some things how can I then next
time I go out I'll try and do something
else yeah yeah again if you can
systematize it as best as possible if
you need to cultivate a capacity within
a social environment get a couple of
buddies or go to a networking event or
do whatever it is that you can do that
routine routine eise's systematizes
habituate the time and attention because
if you have to make that decision every
single time then you're going to end up
using a shitload of willpower to go but
if your friends have already organized
you've already organised to go up some
dinner this evening with my friends I
can't say no and then you're there and
then it rolls in their drinks and before
you know you're in a bar talking to some
people that you've never met before
mmm-hmm sweet whereas if you've got to
drag yourself over well I hadn't plan to
go out and I've got to drag myself out
of bed on my own and I've got going
around and we talk to these people like
grace creating like an architecture
around your day in week that makes the
decisions easy and bad decisions how
stack the deck in your favor yeah 100%
and then I genuinely think that the
power stance things a big deal like if
you walk into a bar like it can be
subtly and I used to do
suddenly sort of go in and you'd stand
feet apart like shoulders back chest
forward and if you do that for about 30
seconds you do feel a little bit my
don't know whether it's placebo but you
just think [ __ ] oh yeah like I don't
have anything to be concerned about in
this situation I mean I can talk to
people and and they're going to be
responsive responsive to me and they're
gonna like me and even if they don't and
so what like is I'm happy with me and
yeah I think in I realize I'm extending
this when we're trying to wrap up but I
think like in that example feeling
confident socially for me I've noticed
as a fluctuation in my confidence when
where I get my value from in my
personality different aspects of my life
like if those are going well I feel
higher sense of self-worth yeah more
confidence if like business is crap
trainings crap of having an argument
with becquer yeah like and you go out
that night I immediately feel totally
different yeah because people are gonna
remember bigger like house so she says I
know it's one of us right it's one of
those things right like you fantastic
yeah buddy great other than like I'm the
[ __ ] ultimate king like live yeah
which is obviously I feel every other
day yeah I think I think you're right
it's it's difficult to have this
indomitable spirit mmm where nothing
extrinsic will affect what's going on
yeah inside your mind and I mean that's
the you can meditate sitting down in
silence right okay now can you meditate
standing up now can you meditate walking
now can you
you know you increase the level of
difficulty if you have the capacity this
is still be confident and still be
outgoing and forthcoming in self believe
it under greater and greater tensions
yeah yeah that would suggest your
natural proclivity to the contrary yeah
that's I mean that's real real true
confidence and I think that's so I mean
I'm not advising at all to try and make
things in your life go really terribly
badly just to see if you can still
remain confident in them like don't
crush a car and then see
so I won't even be able or the night out
yeah that would be a bad idea
have you seen that the video the very
British reaction to a car accident no no
the guys car like goes alright so that's
like merge lettings car tips over and
you like there's a guy rushes over oh my
God he's like okay okay that I'm
uninjured
I'm not even let's let's stay calm about
it's interesting because I I forget
sometimes that use of stone 500 hours of
meditation yeah
and I get really hungry on the road like
you do as a cyclist I've showered at so
many people but that wasn't what I was
going to meet I was gonna say it was if
something so in the context of like you
know little world of propane like little
tiny things go wrong all the time
yep you surface ability to just again
look it so let's bring this back we can
talk to you very briefly we can touch on
confidence in a business perspective a
lot of people are listening may have
desires to run their own business or
have their art projects on the side and
this can apply to within your family
your family is a project in and of
itself you've got a young careers coming
well absolutely
um remember how big of a catastrophe was
when something went wrong five years ago
in your business and then think about
the same thing happening now you just
think things like our first refund
request like what are we talking about
before it's this ability to have
perspective it's the time and attention
it's that when your sample size is only
one year long the outliers that are at
0% and 100% [ __ ] mantle and then
as the sample grows bigger and bigger
you actually realized that zero zero and
a hundred were below the inner quartile
range yeah in 49 and 51 and you think
hang on look at how much more I can ride
the waves in fact the book the
confidence
book by School of Life which is actually
20% this is not in any way affiliated
for a coat it's a it's 20% off at the
moment if you just buy for logic race it
just happens to be Chris 20
the front the front cover of the book is
a Pakal you it's a guillotine going
it's a galleon ship on weight right and
it's that exact thing it's that the your
capacity to ride the waves of life is
very it's very relative like what may
seem like a massive wave now is actually
like yeah
so I think one of the qualities that I
find most admirable and impressive in
people is resilience to things yeah like
something goes catastrophic ly wrong and
someone's just like parts fine well and
I think you business is a good example
because things can go like vertically
like the wrong way instantly yeah and if
you have enough experiences of that at a
greater and greater magnitude over time
I think you just become there's a level
where you just become weights during the
domain of competence again right that
that that issue is within what you would
consider to be I've told this yeah I
kept [ __ ] yeah doing really st.
Darren's like that he's just an
obviously animals that yeah but he's all
he's always been like that he's always
always been like they never had the new
the level of neuroticism that I have
we're going to do one of the upcoming
podcasts that we're going to do is going
to be on the truths about running your
own business and I think that a lot
always yeah yeah that'd be awesome
so you know we thought that we had the
conversation when you were going to
leave start there that's an outfit
accountant company and you were sat down
there so yeah I think definitely
resilience is it's a big deal and I
think having I think if you are in a
position where you're like you hear the
concept of [ __ ] you money
[ __ ] you money like if you there's like
nothing gets anyway me the gambler
something film with Mark Wahlberg Ian
okay and his mentor's like get [ __ ]
money I got a million quid in the bank
and then you're untouchable like no one
can make you do anything
as if you say my tits are like the most
powerful anxiolytic is just like [ __ ]
you money yeah so like if you
financially secure and something bad
happens in a business or a career
because really like businesses is a
representation of like finance just
isn't it yeah yeah so it's very like
Sinbad Oh God
yeah you feel it whereas you sucks just
stood there as Captain Hook outfit at
the at the helm while I get a storm
reaches yeah find the film Everest yes
so you know when the famous writer is
getting picked up in fact this should be
included in the show as this clip says
this is confidence he's getting picked
up from Everest in a helicopter by like
a really like skilled pilot and the
helicopters going like all over it's a
very start right
no it's tough to eat this guys injured
okay and it flashes to the helicopter
pilots face and you just just no emotion
it is it that I swear it to the Stars
right it's at the very very beginning
it's the first it's the first one I
think yeah and he's like going around
them yet he's just completely strike and
he goes like I'm gonna push off the edge
and then we'll go into vertical dive and
then we'll be fine that okay with you
the guy was like good thing is like you
do it's like that it's like the bus
driver in Iceland oh my god two contacts
guys we were in the the biggest storm of
the year we happened to be out the Blue
Lagoon just like playing around in the
water like from from below from here
below it was I was dilated and vascular
from the chest down and then my balloon
avatar dips and like yeah red face
nothing was when we were told when we
were told that in half an hour
and by the way any buses that leave
after half an hour well you will have to
stay here overnight
I remember saying a a vision the
strongest visual representation of your
fear of wasting money there's me empresa
sat in the pool and they go right guys
were closing the saunas look like I've
not been in the soreness running in
flight Chris's flowery shorts over this
bridge in a blizzard in Iceland yes like
everyone's [ __ ] like panicking we're
joined so a driver a backup it's it's
the four then we're getting on the bus
and someone goes like that close the
roads so we got on the bus we were
started about I don't know why we chose
to sit probably feel safer doesn't like
naughty schoolboys yeah so we're back in
this bus and I've got I've still got the
screenshot on my phone of them the
weather app where it said for 20 miles
an hour 43 miles an hour winds and they
were going they were completely adjacent
to the path that we were traveling in so
this high-sided 72 person to see the
coach and this guy and I thought he
didn't compromise on speed yeah so and
we were like the bus was game really
buffeted and it's high side we were
[ __ ] ourselves hmm and I thought
right well my solution is if I go if I
walk to the front of this bus and I look
at the bus driver and he's okay I'm okay
outsourcing right that's because someone
with it with a speciality monitor before
man who look like maybe look yes so walk
done walked onto the front of the bus
expecting to see at least a small amount
of just want to see like as he was just
sat there like this he was in great
spirits too and he's like ah everyone
was getting off in there like thank you
sir
and the only the only time of the trip
that ye looked more alarmed was when you
saw the ready so we everything just
going fine for crits they relate to a
tomato farm and they do we recommend you
buy a lovely tomato drink or beverage of
some sort so I got this weird like sweet
Bloody Mary with lemon and ginger but is
actually off their salary at it we had
really diluted and Chris got the nicest
tomato soup ever for half the price and
I'm suddenly drinking my like 12 pound
horrible drink well I'm like you and I
brought insufficient clothing neither a
room but I headphones we're stuck
together
Chris was three or four seats in front
just Kenny Canada goose zipped all the
way up air pods in fast asleep okay
another stocking hangover though and
that was the morning we're obviously
Pacific asleep in the living room woke
up to watch you try and navigate
portable hob and the first thing he said
to me was I'm making myself an egg would
you like an egg too neck cancer head to
cancer and they're revising I walked
into his into his room and he's starting
about just going how's that what's wrong
man he's like I've just been up sold
what do you mean just beat up stole he
was like I tried to get pieces and
they've sold me and your members
that's a lack of confidence it was just
a good shower do you have to kneel in
that I don't know it was very so far
anyone who hasn't been twice than before
the water is incredibly so free so
smelly yeah you think that the drains
that command back up the shower but then
they're like no you see the Icelandic
water but the typical Icelandic in front
of any product Icelandic butter like and
licorice but it's just normal
over the waterfall how cold water fall
that was the coldest part of the trip
Gullfoss oh yeah and who's what is a
photo of you with the Chinese lady no
that was at the bit where they drown
people that was where the Parliament was
like you'd like to say is that strange
anyway confidence hope everyone's
enjoyed go to Iceland go to Iceland if
you do well I seen this museum got the
paints Museum done by the lamb broth
don't buy the Bloody Mary
don't go cheering a storm don't don't
think that like-minded odds one degree
I've dealt with that before I'll just go
out wearing a [ __ ] doesn't mean is if I
honestly think I was close to I never
saw some kind of genomic yeah yeah and
of course you were fine I was fine you
know what was fine so for the first time
make sure you subscribe YouTube press
like button comment if you've got any
comments or catch us on Instagram
Twitter all the other stuff ok bye doc
goodbye okay buddy
[Music]
you